elon has
made me realize uh how
like good it feels to just not take [ __ ]
seriously every once in a while and just
relieve like
the pressure of the world at the same
time the reason i don't
always like when people finish their
sentences with lol
is like that you don't when you don't
take
anything seriously when everything
becomes a joke
then it feels like uh
that way of thinking feels like it will
destroy the world
it's like i i often think like will mim
save the world to destroy because i
think
both the possible directions yeah i
think this is a big problem i mean
america
i always felt that about america a lot
of people are telling jokes kind of
all the time and they're kind of good at
it
um and you take someone aside
an american you're like i really want to
have a sincere conversation it's like
hard to even keep a straight face yeah
because um
everything is so there's so much levity
so it's complicated i like how sincere
actually like your twitter
can be you're like i am in love with the
world yeah
i get so much [ __ ] for it i'm not i'm
never gonna stop because i realize like
you have to be able to sometimes just be
real and be positive and just be
uh say the cliche things which
ultimately those things actually capture
some fundamental truths about
life yeah but it's it's a dance and i i
think elon does a
a good job of that now from an
engineering perspective of being able to
joke but every once
you know what mostly to pull back and be
like
here's real problems let's solve them
and so on and then be able to jump back
to a joke
so it's uh it's ultimately i think i
guess a skill that we
have to learn i uh but i guess your
advice is to invest
everything uh anywhere listening owns
into deutsche coin
that's what i heard from this yeah
exactly yeah no
hedge fund is unavailable uh just go
straight to dogecoin
you